And, that's it.
We finished creating
our ContentProvider.
Since this has been an involved section,
let's talk about what we created.
We started off by defining the URI's
that our ContentProvider will support.
We then updated our contract
to reflect these URIs.
>From there, we built a URIMatcher that
matches these URIs to constants we use
in switch statements in all of the other
required content provider functions.
Then we implemented the getType
function to return the type of
cursor returned for each URI.
We then implemented
the ContentProvider query functions,
followed by the write operations insert,
update, and delete.
Finally, we talked about
the optional BulkInsert
function to make updates to our
database in a single transaction.
This performs much faster, and causes
less wear and tear on the flash chip,
compared to updating the database
in multiple transaction.
There are lots of libraries out
there in the Android open source
world to help you built
ContentProviders.
If you want to use them,
you'll be able to use them now
with the confidence that you know how
they work, and what they are doing.
So all queries and
updates to the database can now be done
through the ContentProvider interface.
But, we're still not
using it in our code.
Let's fix that.